il y a quelques jours je vous présenter
le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra le
smartphone le plus haut de gamme de
Samsung or bien évidemment smartphone
pliable ici et ça ok c'est ça c'est ça
c'est cette très très très jolie bête et
je vous la montrer j'ai refait des
premières images je me suis baladé avec
et il est l'heure aujourd'hui de donner
mon retour ça fait quelques jours que je
l'ai avec moi j'ai fait plein de photos
je me suis bien amusé j'ai fait plein de
trucs avec et je vais tout vous raconter
sur ce nouveau smartphone vous allez
voir alors j'adore il y a énormément de
choses positives il y a aussi quelques
petits détails qu'il faudrait encore
venir corriger mais globalement le
travail café Samsung ici juste
extraordinaire vous êtes prêt on y va
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec rhinoshield
parce qu'avoir un beau Samsung Galaxy
S23 ultra c'est bien venir le protéger
c'est encore mieux alors vous connaissez
ridoshield j'en ai déjà beaucoup parlé
et en plus la bonne nouvelle c'est que
pendant tout le mois de février profiter
de moins de 10% sur tout l'ensemble du
site rhinoshield avec le code gros 23
grrr23 une fois de plus je vous mets le
lien en bas dans la description alors
regardez ce qui vachement bien chez
rhinoshield entre autres c'est que vous
avez des protections pour vos
smartphones mais pas que et si vous
venez regarder directement vous allez
voir vous avez beaucoup de produits
compatibles et ce qui est génial c'est
qu'ils vont venir vous proposer des
protections pour tous vos smartphones de
Samsung et voyez vont bientôt arriver
sur les Samsung Galaxy S23 donc vous
avez juste à venir cliquer ici pour vous
tenir informé et ça c'est vachement
chouette les coques de rhinoshi sont
extrêmement fines et totalement
personnalisables vous allez retrouver
notamment les solides suite ici avec
différents designs super sympas et ça
c'est vraiment génial il y en a
énormément donc venez jeter un coup
d'oeil et vous allez voir franchement
vous avez de quoi vous marrer et vous
avez en plus énormément de collabs qui
sont super bien dans plein d'univers
alors on va avoir vous le voyez ici vous
avez One Piece il va y avoir Star Wars
snooping naruto shippuden vous en avez
énormément Dragon Ball à NBA League of
Legends les Supers Nanas my hero
academia il y en a vachement France
rugby la NASA bref énormément venez
jeter un coup d'œil directement sur le
site de rhinoshield à tous les coups
vous avez bien trouvé votre bonheur et
vous pouvez en plus venir personnaliser
totalement votre coffre regardez vous
venez vous choisissez votre modèle bon
le S23 ultra va arriver très très
bientôt vous choisissez la couleur de
votre smartphone comme ça vous voyez
réellement ce qu'il en est le modèle ici
ça sera la solitude fatalement la
version standard et là vous avez des
photos collages alors voyons plus mettre
directement vos textes si vous le
souhaitez mettre vos propres photos un
marquage premium pourquoi pas ou même
carrément un maillot si par exemple je
mette une photo allez on va prendre par
exemple cette photo là qui est la photo
de Anne hop je la pose et là je mets la
photo directement sur mon smartphone et
j'ai un smartphone personnalisé avec la
tronche de un dessus ça me fait bien
plaisir mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
puisque rhinoshield a également des
protection envers trempé pour protéger
la vitre de vos smartphones ça c'est
aussi super bien résistance aux traces
de doigts verre trempé 9 heures haute
transparence autre bonne nouvelle pour
la NBA
limiter qui sont sortis et qui sont
également disponibles pour iPhone et ça
c'est très chouette une fois de plus je
vous invite à acheter un coup d'œil
directement sur le site de rhinoshield
pour venir trouver votre bonheur je vous
mets le lien en bas dans la description
et n'oubliez pas profiter de 10% sur
tout le mois février ça c'est très très
chouette merci à rhinoshield d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo
alors qu'est-ce raconte ce Samsung
Galaxy S23 ultra alors le S23 ultra
c'est un smartphone qui est très à part
si on vient de mettre en face du S23
s23+ qui sont des smartphones un peu
plus conventionnels celui-là et bien
c'est un choix qui est vraiment tout
autre c'est l'évolution de la gamme note
qu'on a connu qui est décédé on a déjà
parlé avec le fameux Espagne qu'on peut
venir utiliser pour aborder airsters
pour écrire pour prendre des notes et si
et ça mais si vous n'êtes pas intéressé
par le spa et bien c'est pas grave parce
que ce smartphone il y en a vraiment
sous le capot à commencer par la photo
alors ici vous n'aurez pas loupé vous
avez cinq capteurs photos vous avez un
grand angle vous avez un ultra grand
temps que vous avez deux téléobjectifs
bref c'est un truc de dingue alors il y
a beaucoup de sujets à venir regarder
ici il est excellent dans beaucoup de
domaines et c'est vraiment ça qui est
super intéressant vous avez aussi bien
de la macro de la photo de nourriture de
la photo de nuit si et ça je vais vous
montrer des photos de jour déjà que j'ai
fait j'ai énormément de photos comme ça
je vais tout vous montrer je vous montre
quelques photos regardez ça dans un
hôtel grand angle ultra grand angle ça
c'est de la nourriture alors je vous
montrerai d'autres photos de nourriture
mais il est vraiment très très bon dans
le mode nourriture et vous sort des
trucs qui sont très précis regardez une
fois de plus regardez détails qu'on a
ici là sur la tomate qui sont juste
magnifique voyez on a presque un petit
veinage parce que c'est pas du V9 parce
qu'il y a de 20 sur la tomate je ne
pense pas mais c'est super beau et
c'était d'ailleurs très très bon ça
c'est mon pote a une coucou Anne je me
disais à le prendre en photo avec mon
iPhone et le prendre en photo en plus
avec le Galaxy S23 ultra c'est n'importe
quoi mais c'est chouette et en fait ce
que j'aime bien c'est que déjà il y a
une vraie belle cohérence au niveau de
la colorimétrie une petite différence
légèrement au niveau du bleuté qu'on va
retrouver sur l'ultra grand-angle mais
globalement c'est très très bon on peut
venir beaucoup se rapprocher en zoomant
alors on va pas aller jusqu'au space
zoom fois 100 mais parce que c'est pas
ouf mais regardez au niveau de la
gestion de la lumière c'est dingue là je
suis en plein sur les gens contre le
jour de ma boule dans la photo et pour
autant surtout je vois tout le bâtiment
j'ai même le reflet qui est extrêmement
préservé j'ai bien le soleil je vois la
façade du bâtiment en face c'est
absolument incroyable ce qui est capable
de venir vous faire ce smartphone ici
n'oublions pas qu'on a la très grosse
capacité de calcul du snack dragon à 8
GN 2 derrière et ça marche bien sur le
grand angle sur l'ultra grand-angle
regardez-moi tous ces rayons de soleil
autour c'est juste magnifique ce qui
nous fait ici l'herbe et vert bien
saturé ils aiment bien saturer chez
Samsung mais globalement comme celle-là
ça va de façon il faisait froid donc bon
ça me pose pas de souci une fois de plus
j'ai bien tout le bâtiment sur le côté
j'ai un peu Lens flair ici mais ça va
franchement c'est super bien alors après
je peux venir zoomer un peu c'est là où
c'est super impressionnant c'est que je
continue à avoir mon reflexe que tu veux
faire mon bâtiment la façade que je vois
très bien tout est clair et le soleil ne
pose absolument aucun problème et même
lorsque vous avez le soleil dans le dos
vous voyez c'est très joli une petite
différence un peu plus bleu au niveau de
l'ultra grand-angle mais ça se joue à
pas grand chose et je trouve que c'est
vraiment bien le détail lorsque je viens
zoomer c'est dingue regardez là là les
détails alors là effectivement on leur
voit que ça a joué au niveau numérique
mais c'est beau c'est clair c'est net
une fois de plus à contre-jour je lis
tout très bien c'est vraiment
extrêmement bien maîtrisé c'est beau
c'est joli l'ultra grand-angle et pas
déformant on a un truc qui est fou et je
trouve que Samsung a fait un excellent
boulot ici regardez jusqu'où on peut
venir aller alors ça sert à rien d'aller
aussi loin mais globalement je trouve ça
vraiment top alors je vous laisse un peu
plus une fois plus un peu saturé ils
aiment bien saturer ça me saoule c'est
vraiment un peu leur petit truc l'herbe
est très très verte on dit souvent
l'herbe est plus verte ailleurs mais je
peux assurer que c'est très très vert
chez Samsung et le ciel est très très
bleu chez Samsung et le taf est là le
taf est fait donc pour moi vous êtes sur
votre grand-angle votre ultra
grand-angle et après vous venez avec un
zoom optique x 3 zoom optique x 10 et
après vous montez en x 30 x 50 vous
voyez bon le Space zoom façon on sait
pas ouf histoire de se marrer on peut le
faire il vous le mettre parce que on
peut le faire mais il s'est strictement
rien jusqu'en x 30 c'est bien au-delà de
ça voilà ça commence vraiment à se
dégrader mais je trouve que vraiment une
fois de plus le détailler là il y a un
piqué c'est beau j'adore ça alors la
caméra de selfie je vous montrerai
d'autres choses faites avec la caméra
selfie c'est pas mauvais c'est pas mal
ça fonctionne bien même à contre-jour
lorsqu'on vient un petit peu le chercher
bien je trouve que globalement il
travaille vachement bien donc ça je
voulais montrer je voulais vous montrer
ici on est vraiment chercher voyez ça en
fait ces petites barres là et bien c'est
les barres que vous avez là-haut là vous
voyez juste ici il a les deux petites
barres et bien c'est ce qu'on va venir
chercher ici alors voilà on montre un
peu la puissance du Space zoom x 100 et
je trouve que l'algo est bon parce que
on voit vraiment il prend la photo et
d'un coup on le voit qui corrige qui
améliore et c'est pas mal et je trouve
que il est vraiment pas partout c'est
vraiment un couteau suisse ce smartphone
et c'est ça que j'adore choper dans un
ascenseur comme ça je trouve ça assez
marrant et une fois de plus regardez
bien l'avion là vous le voyez au fond
l'avion et ben on va venir chercher avec
le Space zoom on vient le chercher voilà
et on a cherché l'avion au fond c'est
fou alors bon ça c'est un petit peu
bougé mais je trouve que sinon c'est
vraiment bien donc voilà je voulais
montrer c'est c'est première images
alors je vais vous montrer d'autres
trucs c'est pas les premières images
c'est des images que j'ai fait je vais
vous montrer tout à l'heure un peu de
nourriture on va se regarder d'autres
photos de nourriture regardez-moi ça
alors là j'ai un peu bougé ça c'était
mais à coup le passé moi mais c'est
vraiment bien alors attention la photo
de nourriture ça fait vraiment centré
sur un élément de la nourriture c'est
pas partout mais vous avez vraiment un
élément qui est vraiment mis en avant
alors là j'ai la tête zoomer voilà
j'avais zoomer dans l'image voilà
c'était pas terrible on voit tout de
suite c'est c'est pas là faut quand même
pas trop trop bien zoomer mais sinon
globalement alors bon ça on passe je
trouve ça pas mal quoi vous voyez les
détails au niveau de la nourriture on de
toutes les petites pilosité là sur la
sur la fleur qui était d'ailleurs pas
mal du tout et on va bien une fois plus
regarder vous avez ça qui est le point
est là tout le reste au tour est flou
c'est vraiment une zone qui est claire
mais je trouve ça vachement bien ça me
donne faim encore c'est impressionnant
donc ça je vous ai montré je voulais
vous montrer d'autres trucs que je
trouve intéressant également alors là
macro on peut venir faire également un
peu de macro alors moi je vous ai fait
de la macro sur mon canapé voilà
bienvenue à la maison voilà regardez ça
là ça là le détail de la fibre on a bien
tous les petits poils de la fibre
regardez même comme ça là je trouve ça
bien fait alors moi je suis globalement
pas trop fan de macro mais quand on
vient me chercher un peu de maquereau
avec beaucoup de définition derrière et
que vous avez des détails qui est très
clair très beau et qui a pas une espèce
d'algo qui vient vous compenser avec une
caméra à 2 mégapixels ou 5 mégapixels
qui est complètement pourri là vous avez
un truc qui est très très bien et on
peut venir zoomer dans l'image vous
voyez alors on peut venir zoomer
jusqu'en foi 1,9 après vous changez
d'objectif et là le boulot est fini il
veut plus on peut plus donc on peut
venir jusqu'à 1 x 0,9 dire zoom un peu
mais regardez c'est quand même pas mal
fait ça c'est un kiwi si vous vous
demandez c'est un kiwi je suis venu sur
un kiwi et la regarder on a un peu de
détails de kiwi alors bon c'est pas mais
c'est bien ça c'est de l'orange et je
trouve que globalement il y a un truc
qui est pas mal et qui marche quand même
vachement bien ici alors on continue
avec d'autres choses que je voulais
venir vous montrer alors j'étais une
conférence conférence de TP Vision chez
Philips TV et audio et je voulais vous
montrer parce que c'est l'endroit où il
y a pas beaucoup de luminosité et on
arrive à des choses qui sont très très
bien et très bonne qualité vous voyez là
au niveau du détail du crâne du monsieur
ici là là je trouve c'est vraiment
vraiment bien alors je viens zoomer un
peu dedans bon si je viens trop près
vous voyez l'algo compense et pas bien
en plus il y a l'écran derrière il a un
peu plus de mal mais on sort des choses
qui sont quand même pas dégueu ça c'est
assez marrant vous voyez comme ça là je
trouve ça vraiment pas mal en mettant
vous voyez la nouvelle gamme de Philips
the extra c'est Samsung qui va faire la
gueule en voyant ça mais c'est comme ça
c'est la vie hein mais non bon on va pas
trop bien zoomer mais je trouve que
sinon c'est vraiment bien une fois de
plus j'étais assez de distance en fait
vous voyez donc ça ça me va bien et ça
fonctionne très très bien qu'est-ce que
je veux vous montrer encore mode
portrait de jour alors je vais vous
montrer deux photos que j'ai
sélectionnées ici vous allez voir la
puissance du bouzin et bien alors
regardez alors là il a eu un poil de mal
ici entre les doigts là voyez ça il
s'est dit c'est quoi ce bordel là il a
pas trop suggéré mais sinon ils s'en
sort quand même pas trop mal là il a eu
un peu de mal au dessus de ma tête vous
voyez c'est petit point de détails là où
il a eu un peu de mal mais je trouve que
globalement le taf est fait là c'est
pareil vous avez le détourage est clean
bien alors puisque je vous le montre le
jour je vous le montrer la nuit parce
que la nuit les photos de portrait de
nuit sont bluffantes et tout ce qui est
fait au niveau de la nuit et bleu fond
regardez ça alors il y a différents
modes mais c'est quand même vachement
cool c'est-à-dire que le détourage est
vraiment bien maîtrisé il y a une super
ambiance au niveau de la lumière c'est
totalement bien maîtrisé alors là j'ai
tendance il y avait beaucoup de
différentes lumières vous voyez il
détour et on a toujours le
petit-déjeuner de lumière autour et
c'est le petit bémol qu'on a ici c'est
que c'est pas totalement parfait mais ça
me fait un petit liseré ça fait un petit
effet et globalement je trouve que ça
fonctionne sur cette photo également et
lorsque vous êtes là où il y a vraiment
les lumières et qu'on met les lumières
et bien vous le voyez ici le bleu il
venait de là et c'est pour ça qu'il
avait un peu de mal mais sinon c'est
très très bien vous voyez le flou est
net s'il y a un vrai détail sur la photo
c'est très joli personnellement je
trouve que le taf est vraiment très très
bien alors il avait perdu un peu la j'ai
une espèce de petite boucle sur ma veste
qu'il a perdu qu'il a confondu du point
de détail mais je trouve que globalement
il y a vraiment très très très joli
boulot qui est fait ici donc ça c'est
pour le portrait de nuit je vais vous
montrer des photos de nuit parce que
pour moi la nuit ce smartphone il est
incroyable vous allez voir j'ai fait la
photo de nuit normale en 12 mégapixels
j'ai fait en 50 megapixels et en 200
mégapixels et vous allez voir que il
faut pas trop venir à chercher à monter
parce qu'il y a des choses qui sont un
peu un peu arbres mais globalement on a
des gens qui sont vraiment très très
très très très très jolie sur la photo
de nuit en 12 mégapixels c'est
incroyable regardez ça les lampes là
j'ai pas de Lens flair ça marche bien
c'est joli c'est maîtrisé tout est bien
illuminé le ciel est beau il y a un côté
un peu cotonneux je trouve que ils ont
vraiment bien bossé coucou à Brandon qui
tient la lumière en boîte et
regardez-moi ça là on est dans un club
c'est le patchanama je crois avait un
Bastille et c'est pas mal là un peu de
lance flair très léger mais une fois de
plus j'aime bien ce rendu il y a un côté
très doux là vous voyez au niveau des
arbres j'aime beaucoup ça c'est joli
regarde là c'est plein de balle lance
quand même votre lumière elle vient un
peu faire des comment vous dire des
effets qui sortent de la lumière en fait
c'est que le truc qui marche pas très
bien où il est un petit peu de mal vous
voyez c'est tous ces effets là qu'on va
retrouver ça c'est à cause de vos
objectifs la que je suis venu shooter
ici avec le Space zoom poisson on a
quand même du détail c'est regarder ça
c'est en voie du bois quand même je
trouve ça toujours extrêmement bluffant
d'autres photos coucher de soleil un peu
là on est à Clermont-Ferrand on se
balade un petit peu mise à part le lens
flare qu'on a ici qu'on retrouve quand
même pas mal à différents endroits et je
trouve que le le boulot est vraiment
bien fait avec une douceur j'aime
beaucoup cette douceur qu'on est au
niveau de l'image vous voyez là il y a
des tanks qui sont très douces et que
j'avais pas avant et que je retrouve
vraiment aussi sur ce 23 ultra d'autres
photos qui ont été prises vraiment les
trucs sont super beau le problème c'est
le lance flair mais au-delà de ça ça
fonctionne bien tout a été pris ça à
Amsterdam sur un événement une fois de
plus le Lens sphère qui vient un peu
la photo c'est dommage parce que
le reste est quand même très joli voilà
il est un peu tous ces problèmes là là
c'est ça c'est ça le truc si j'arrive
vraiment à corriger ça dans un truc qui
serait encore plus over the top déjà là
c'est super beau c'est très joli coucou
Anne qui prend la pose devant le
barbecue qui n'est pas réellement
barbecue j'aime bien la couleur j'aime
bien la netteté j'aime bien tout le
travail qu'ils ont fait regarder ça là
au niveau des mains et monsieur est en
train de faire un cocktail en fait donc
vous voyez tout qui bouge comme ça et je
trouve ça incroyable c'était la teuf et
je trouve ça bien c'est vraiment je joue
je joue du Shoo je shoot en rafale et
globalement on gagner des images comme
ça qui sont quand même pas mal du tout
et des fois qui sont très très jolis là
il a eu un peu plus de mal là très
clairement on va le dire là peut-être
parce que j'ai shooté j'ai bougé en même
temps j'en sais rien mais alors là la
photo elle est morte de chez moi elle
est pourrie de chez pourrie mais sinon
il y a des gens qui sont vraiment très
très bien là il a eu un peu de mal aussi
également donc avec deux trois petits
trucs des fois au niveau des éclairages
où il va avoir un peu de mal c'est tout
ce problème je pense au niveau de
l'optique qui va regarder là il va lui
poser quelques petits problèmes mais sur
certains moments parce que dans
l'ensemble le taf est vraiment bien fait
ça c'est très joli après si des fois je
bouge moi aussi je vous raconte pas ça
fout un peu le bordel mais je trouve ça
bien d'autres photos qu'on est venu
shooter ici avec différentes lumières il
fait pas très chaud avec Anne derrière
j'aime bien l'ambiance qui ressort avec
la l'écran du smartphone qui m'éclaire
le visage tout ça c'est assez marrant
euh voyez toujours le problème de Lens
flair ici ça c'est vraiment le gros truc
que je vais venir reprocher mais sinon
les couleurs sont belles c'est nette
c'est saturé c'est beau ça marche
vraiment bien donc vous voyez au niveau
de la photo nuit j'ai rien à l'approcher
on va regarder la photo de nuit en 50
megapixels vous allez voir que c'est
quand même un peu différent je trouve ça
un peu moins bon globalement ça
fonctionne un peu près là où j'ai
vraiment du problème c'est ça on fait le
même genre le problème avec l'éclairage
de face là il voulait pas le faire le
vrai problème que j'ai lancé sur le 200
mégapixels sur le 200 mégapixels je
trouve que on est quand même un peu en
dessous et c'est un peu moins bon je
monte d'autres images sur le 200
mégapixels regardez déjà il a beaucoup
plus de mal à venir compenser l'algo va
pas fonctionner pareil parce que sur le
50 mégapixels vous avez du pixel Bining
on regroupe 4 pixels en un seul et même
gros pixels pour venir effectivement
compenser les lumières en 200 mégapixels
ça n'existe pas chaque pixel est
indépendant et ce qui fait que vous
retrouvez avec des éclairages des fois
qui montre un petit peu plus complexes
donc il faut vraiment une scène qu'on va
venir davantage maîtriser voyez les
télés on va strictement plus rien alors
sur 12 mégapixels on voyait bien la
voyez là tout ça là il a tout de suite
beaucoup plus de mal pareil au niveau
des lumières ça change ça bouge il a
beaucoup de mal sur le 200 mégapixels
donc bon 200 mégapixels ouais ils vont
mieux maîtriser un peu sa scène sans
quoi c'est rapidement le rapidement le
bazar mais dans l'ensemble ils en sont
quand même vachement bien un selfie que
je suis venu prendre la nuit c'est pas
mauvais honnêtement c'est pas mal c'est
même plutôt bien c'est pas ce que je
vais préférerais c'est le film faut de
la lumière il faut faire le jour bon ça
fait le taf et je vous montre quelques
autres photos de selfie alors il y en a
assez peu de lumière ça marche moins
bien mais dès lors que vous avez de la
lumière vous êtes à l'extérieur même sur
le contre une fois de plus l'algorithme
fait le taf et ça marche quand même bien
puisque je vous disais que c'est un
smartphone couteau suisse c'est
réellement ça
parce que pour le l'expert RA
W il faut venir la télécharger et sinon
plus vous verrez dans un petit icône
pour dire la télécharger l'experto et
cette expérience parce qu'elle vous
permet d'aller beaucoup plus loin faire
beaucoup plus de choses notamment des
photos en astrophotographie regardez
vous cliquez là vous l'avez et là vous
voyez la durée de votre exposition Guide
du Ciel oui non et vous montez jusqu'à
là j'ai 7 minutes et là je suis jusqu'à
10 minutes donc si vous voulez faire de
la poste très longue pour la soit
photographie ou même pas que la
sophotographie et bien vous pouvez venir
le faire ici et vous avez dans cette
application pas mal de choses des petits
réglages vous pouvez faire vous-même
donc là vraiment plus dans le mode
professionnel on n'est pas forcément
dans le mode que monsieur madame tout le
monde va venir utiliser mais une fois de
plus que je trouve très bien c'est que
vous avez celle-là que vous avez
également le mode Pro vous allez pouvoir
venir faire vos réglages directement
mais vous n'aurez pas la sauce
photographie ici et puis vous avez quand
même beaucoup de modes je vous le disais
tout à l'heure vous avez le mode
nourriture le super ralenti le panorama
le ralenti l'hyperlapse la vidéo
portrait la vue du réalisateur le mode
single take il va tout faire pour vous
de façon un peu automatique bref un vrai
couteau suisse ici alors je vous ai
montré la photo je vous montre
maintenant la vidéo j'ai été extrêmement
bluffé parce que j'ai vu au niveau de la
photo pourquoi déjà au niveau de la
stabilisation alors moi je tremble j'ai
problèmes essentiel c'est le bordel en
plus je suis un mec hyper speed donc ça
n'aide pas et bien vous avez une super
stabilisation ici et c'est vraiment un
truc que j'ai adoré regarder c'est juste
hyper stabilisé c'est très cool au même
un bouge et bien le rendu que vous allez
avoir au final ne bougera pas et je
trouve ça vraiment très très bien alors
j'ai fait plein plein plein de vidéos
différentes vous voyez ça c'est sur la
conflit par exemple toujours la même
conférence alors je suis venu zoomer le
zoom est très très soumousse ça va
vachement bien alors on va pas trop
zoomer au bout d'un moment ça va pas
aller vous restez sur votre téléobjectif
33 c'est bien au-delà de ça vous voyez
on perd quand même vachement qualité et
c'est pas Dingo donc on va venir éviter
mais ce que je vais trouver je vais vous
montrer que je trouve vraiment vraiment
intéressant c'est lorsque je prends le
smartphone et que je viens de déplacer
et bien j'ai un truc qui est vachement
alors là vous voyez toujours le problème
du lance flair que je vais venir
retrouver ça c'est mon problème
d'optique et c'est un truc qui a
vraiment venir corriger c'est dommage
parce que une fois que j'ai viré ça j'ai
un truc qui est parfait et qui est
vraiment vraiment super bien regardez
lorsque je suis en train de filmer Anne
coucou Anne et bien je tiens tout ça à
la main je trouve ça nette c'est
stabilisé ça bouge pas c'est clair je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment bien et pour
moi il y a un vrai gros gros boulot qui
a été ici de la part de Samsung c'est à
dire que si vous voulez prendre votre
smartphone à la main on the Go vous
filmez vous partez vous prenez un peu
l'arrache vous avez pas besoin d'avoir
un stabilisateur vous avez pas besoin de
tout ça il est extrêmement bien
stabilisé même jusqu'en 8 à 30 images
par seconde c'est de la 4K 60 là mais
vous voyez si je vais faire de la 8k et
bien par exemple j'aurais un truc qui
sera aussi super bien stabilisé là vous
voyez faire des petits travelling à la
main je trouve ça très bien en plus de
ça la qualité de l'image est très très
bonne le fichier est super cool je peux
venir marrer je peux venir me rapprocher
sur plein de choses bref je trouve que
ils ont vraiment fait un super joli
boulot j'ai fait un peu de vidéo de nuit
histoire de vous montrer histoire de se
marrer et je trouve ça bien globalement
alors il sera moins bon qu'un jour on va
avoir un peu plus de bruit vous voyez on
va voir un petit peu plus de mal mais
dans l'idée je trouve que il s'en sort
quand même plutôt pas trop mal et c'est
vrai que là-dessus une fois de plus
Samsung a vraiment bien bossé au niveau
de sa photo au niveau de sa vidéo on a
un smartphone qui est juste excellent si
vous voulez venir le prendre pour
shooter tous les jours vous amuser sans
problème un vrai bel outil pour les
créatifs même pour les professionnels
qui veulent avoir un outil très facile à
venir utiliser alors attention venez
mettre un petit micro en plus notamment
je vous recommanderais sur le dji Mike
génial parce que vous le branchez
directement dessus et qui est très très
cool je vous ai fait une vidéo pour vous
en parler allez jeter un œil parce que
c'est vraiment un très très joli produit
et bien vous avez pas besoin près
d'apprendre à stabilisateur vous le
prenez vous vous balader vous faites vos
plantes enfin bref c'est vraiment un
super photophone et vidéophone si on
arrive à supprimer ce petit côté de Lens
flair et bien il serait juste 100 %
incroyable déjà super bon il est
vraiment exceptionnel mais il irait
encore plus loin et déjà là je vous dis
une fois de plus le boulot est fait donc
pour tout ce qui va être vidéo photo il
est très bon il est au top il marche
très très bien et il vous conviendra
sans aucun problème une totalement au
niveau d'un iPhone 14 pro max et d'un
pixel cell pro on sera un petit comparo
bientôt comme ça on pourra regarder
maintenant je regarde un peu ce qui
raconte d'un point de vue multimédia et
bien vous avez une dalle qui est juste
magnifique si vous voulez venir vous
amuser regardez du bon contenu vous avez
une dalle de 6,8 pouces elle est super
qualité c'est la dynamique à molette 2x
bref je vous passe le truc taux de
rafraîchissement qui descend jusqu'à 1 h
jusqu'à 120 Hertz pour tout ce qui va
être contenu extrêmement fluide navigué
sur les réseaux sociaux vous voyez vous
avez un truc qui est très nette pour le
gaming c'est aussi extrêmement net bref
c'est un smartphone qui est génial
là-dessus pour venir regarder du contenu
ça marche vachement bien alors je vous
montre ici moi sur mon écran ce que ça
raconte c'est vraiment vraiment cool
honnêtement je vous assure ça marche
bien le seul truc vous voyez c'est vous
pousser la je vous mets la luminosité
vraiment fort vous en rendrez pas compte
c'est pas extrêmement évident mais il
est très lumineux en extérieur ça marche
vous le voyez vraiment bien l'écran est
légèrement incurvé alors moi j'aime bien
cet écran légèrement curvé mais il y en
a qui aime pas trop donc bon ça va
dépendre c'est une question de goût et
de couleur ici mais le rendu est
vraiment bien le seul point un peu
négatif qu'on aura au niveau de
l'expérience multimédia c'est l'audio
parce que je le trouve un peu trop
médium il va manquer un peu de grade
vous voyez
[Musique]
est assez bonne il y a du son il y a un
gros gros volume derrière mais ça manque
un peu de couilles quoi soyons clair ça
manque vraiment grave et c'est le truc
on va venir un peu lui reprocher c'est
il existe des smartphones qui
déploieront des graves mais lui un peu
moyen donc vous venez le connecter en
Bluetooth vous le mettez des Galaxy
Bulls derrière ou ce que vous voulez et
vous aurez un son qui sera bien meilleur
et vous allez venir maximiser
l'expérience donc ça c'est truc qui a un
peu dommage ça me saoule aurait pu aller
un peu plus loin au niveau de l'audio
mais pour tout le reste la qualité est
vraiment vraiment cool regardez je vous
montre vous allez dans vos paramètres
vous venez ici au niveau de votre écran
vous avez voilà un truc qui marche
vachement bien tu as une clé Artem
sombre le confort visuel si on veut
qu'il y a le jaunir un peu plus mais ça
conviendra parfaitement ça va dépendre
de vous le mode d'écran moi je suis en
vif il y a une natural si on veut mais
je préfère le vivre quand même qui est
un peu plus sympa un peu plus blanc qui
est plus joli la résolution on peut
monter en wqhd plus mais rester en Full
HD plus ça sert à rien de pousser la
résolution trop si ce n'est de venir
consommer davantage fluidité des
mouvements adaptatif ici vous le laissez
un adaptatif et lui fait sa sauce tout
seul il se
des éléments mais si vous voulez venir
l'utiliser tous les jours et que vous
voulez pas vous prendre la tête vous
pouvez y aller alors le point un peu
négatif ici c'est que le bloc de charge
n'est pas inclus c'est du 45 watts c'est
de la recharge rapide alors il existe
des smartphones qui sont chargeront
encore plus vite mais en 45 watts ça
fait le taf vous inquiétez pas il y a
absolument pas de problème par contre il
faut venir acheter votre bloc de charge
à part bon c'est toujours des questions
d'écologie Samsung nous a beaucoup dit
qu'ils étaient très soucieux à
l'écologie aujourd'hui la loi n'impose
pas au constructeur de vignette des
blocs de charge avec à moins que des
écouteurs donc vous n'avez mis écouteur
ni bloc de charge vous avez néanmoins un
câble mais c'est tout donc si vous
n'avez pas un bloc de charge 45 watts ou
25 watts de chez vous et bien il va
falloir en acheter je vous recommande
quand même le 45 watts de batterie de
5000 mai il faut un petit peu de temps
pour venir la recharger et alors l'autre
truc qui est bien et ça on en parle
également je sais pas si j'aurais sorti
ma vidéo avant ou après mais c'est
l'expérience logiciel c'est one US 5.1
avec des petites mises à jour qui sont
intéressantes notamment voyez ici je
peux venir me sélectionner ça va venir
me reconnaître je peux venir faire un
petit copier je peux venir faire un
petit collier alors j'irai pas aussi
loin que ce qu'on me propose Apple avec
son iOS mais globalement il y a des
choses qui sont assez intéressantes ici
j'en parle une fois de sur Youtube donc
venez jeter un coup d'oeil sur ma vidéo
donc l'expérience manuelle elle est
bonne elle est lisible elle est claire
elle est très sympa c'est une des
préférés le problème c'est que ça prend
beaucoup de place je crois que j'ai 46
Go qui seront pris ici en stockage que
par mon OS donc si vous voulez venir
prendre par exemple et bien un
smartphone sans être 8 Go sachez que
vous avez déjà 45 giga qui est pris par
là alors quand je vous parle de 128 Go
c'est uniquement sur le S23 et S23 + 6
semble-t-il parce que lui de toute façon
il commence en 256 Go donc ça c'est
c'est déjà moins de mal vous êtes déjà
un peu plus payant là-dessus au sujet
qui est intéressant mais bon il y a rien
de bien neuf sous le soleil c'est le
Space alors moi je suis pas un grand
utilisateur de Spain c'est pas trop mon
truc mais si vous voulez venir prendre
des notes facilement bien vous pouvez
venir créer une note vous pouvez venir
dessiner vous pouvez venir griffonner
faire ce que vous voulez gommer bref si
ça vous intéresse si c'est votre truc
moi je suis pas une fois de plus fana du
SPN mais je trouve cool pour la prise de
photo à distance pour la prise de notes
vous avez pas mal de réaction ici qu'on
vient vous proposer donc why not c'est
plutôt bien ça va dans la question de la
productivité parce que c'est un
smartphone là je vous montre beaucoup
l'usage un peu plus récréatif photo
divertissement essayez mais vous pouvez
vraiment venir l'utiliser pour de la
productivité faire le lien en plus avec
l'écosystème de Samsung notamment les
galaxies book 3 qui ont été présentés
dans ton reparlera bientôt par la
probablement du Galaxy Boop 3 ultra
cadette très intéressant donc vous
faites tout connecter tous vos appareils
et vos Galaxy bots ce codec d'un côté
l'autre votre smartphone va pouvoir se
connecter très facilement avec une
tablette avec également un ordinateur
bref vous allez pouvoir venir piloter
votre ordinateur directement depuis
votre Galaxy book 3 bref une solution
qui est très complète qui est très cool
très belle écosystème mais ça c'est
encore un autre sujet maintenant là où
ça fait un petit peu mal c'est que le
smartphone est un petit peu cher
fatalement va s'en douter cette jolie
petite bête là elle coûte 1419 euros
dans la version 256 Go de stockage avec
8 Go de RAM
1599 € c'est un petit budget également
on va pas se cacher en 12 gigas de RAM
cette fois-ci et 512 il y a de stockage
et 1839 euros en 12 il y a de RAM et 1
Tera de stockage l'autre bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'avec ce smartphone vous avez ce
qui s'est mis aujourd'hui vous avez du
wi-fi seul en fait pas encore de wifi 7
ça arrivera l'année prochaine notamment
sur galaxy S24 je pense que ça arrivera
l'année prochaine sans trop de doute
pour l'instant vous avez quand même du
wifi ce en indice de réparabilité qui
est très cool à 8,2 sur 10 donc un
smartphone qu'on peut venir réparer
c'est toutefois il y avait un problème
et puis autre sujet qui est important
ici il peut 68 bien évidemment et
Samsung nous a annoncé je vous le redis
une fois de plus parce que c'est 5 ans
de mise à jour de sécurité et 4 ans mise
à jour Android vous aurez les prochaines
versions d'Android donc là on Android 13
vous aurez Android 14 et 15 Android 16
bref ça va loin ça c'est plutôt bien
parce qu'ils savent aujourd'hui ça me
saoule et tous les autres constructeurs
que on va garder plus longtemps sur
smartphone à la main donc c'est normal
et ça c'est très très chouette donc pour
moi ce Galaxy S23 Ultra est un des
meilleurs smartphones que j'ai vu pour
l'instant sur l'année
2023 je trouve excellent photos je
trouve très bon en vidéo il a une
superbe dalle un très bel écran beaucoup
de performances il a une très très belle
autonomie il est cher il est un peu
lourd il est gros la prise en main sera
à deux mains donc c'est pas forcément
fait pour tout le monde il est très bon
aussi au niveau de la productivité il
est très polyvalent avec son respect
l'audio est pas fou fou il y a quelques
trucs qui m'ont voilà viennent un peu me
chiffonner le Lens flair au niveau de la
photo de nuit mais ça reste du point de
détail vu tout ce qu'il peut faire et
toutes les qualités qu'il a à côté
l'expérience logiciel est magnifique
bref pour moi c'est un oui c'est un très
gros oui donc si vous voulez acheter un
magnifique smartphone et que vous aimez
Samsung que vous aimez Android et bien
vous pouvez aller pour moi les yeux
fermés sur ce Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra
dès lors que vous avez 1400 1500 euros à
venir mettre dans un smartphone
d'ailleurs dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez ce que ce smartphone pourrait
vous plaire est-ce qu'il pourrait vous
tenter est-ce qu'il vous plaît est-ce
qu'il vous botte marquez moi tout ça en
bas dans les commentaires et puis on
continuera à parler de Samsung il y a le
test du S23 S23 plus qu'on va grouper
ensemble parce que son globalement
quasiment les mêmes smartphones on va
regarder ça d'ici quelques jours très
très rapidement donc rester connecté
abonnez-vous c'est pas déjà fait voilà
je vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et
à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]